- Hey guys.
First of all, thank you for clicking.
You're about to watch a
new video, or another video
on YouTube and before
you do, 212-931-5731.
What I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers,
it's instant, it's access, it's exclusive,
and now enjoy this YouTube video.
Almost everybody's watching this vlog.
It's spending an hour on dumb shit
that's actually a 12-minute meeting.
Don't make 12-minute
meetings one-hour meetings.
It's nonsense.
You guys want perspective.
(techno music)
(engine hums)
(soft music)
For me, what I've done for
the last 12 years, for sure,
is continue to beat a drum publicly
about where are the opportunities
to garner organic reach
that quote, unquote you don't deserve.
Meaning, the people listening right now,
you start a TikTok account,
you post something,
and 200,000 people watch it.
D Rock, it was this morning, right?
Sunan just posted something in our thread.
I think somebody left a comment
saying their first video
on TikTok got 400,000 views.
That's what early Twitter did,
that's what early Facebook did,
that's what early YouTube did.
Most of the people right now know
that you don't post a YouTube,
you don't tweet a tweet,
you don't post a Facebook post,
and magically all these people see it.
In fact, including Instagram,
almost nobody sees it.
There are always times where
organic reach is popping
on a platform because there's
more attention on the platform
than there is content
filling that attention.
Currently, the two places
that that's happening
are TikTok and LinkedIn.
So, obviously for a lot of
people listening and watching,
LinkedIn is gonna make more sense.
The reason TikTok, you know it's funny,
I'm saying both of them pretty equally.
It's that TikTok, for most
humans when they hear that,
is the place where their
11-year-old daughter
or niece is on.
So, they find it funny, it seems weirder.
You should've seen the backlash,
or not the backlash, the pushback I got
when I was yelling about
Facebook in 2010, 11, 12.
People still considered that
a college social network.
So, yeah, I want to be
historically correct.
I want to bring the most
value as an entrepreneur
to entrepreneurs.
And the way I know how
to do that is to for free
put out content that
inspires and gives insights
to places where there's opportunity.
TikTok's single most important thing
for everybody who's
listening is the following.
If it goes older,
it it adds photos instead
of just these videos,
if it evolves no different
than the way Instagram evolved.
Instagram had to add stories
to stop a fast-moving Snapchat
that was gaining market share.
If they evolve and if the demo gets older,
I do believe it becomes
a very important place
for people in 24 and 36 months
trying to sell real estate,
sneakers, courses, clothes, whatever.
But if it doesn't, and this
is the most important part.
If it doesn't, it already has
hundreds of millions of people
reacting to it.
So, some of the behaviors on
it inevitably will be things
that we as creators and
communicators need to add
to our repertoire, whether
that happens on Instagram
because of a feature change
or lipstick comes out and
becomes the next thing
with 30% nuances of TikTok.
I became a great creator
because I was on Socialcam,
I was on Vine, I was on Peach.
I was on all these things
that did not go on to win,
but I was learning.
And by the way, when I was on
Vine, I got value out of that.
Right now, I've built a
huge audience on TikTok.
I've had more people
stop me under 15 saying,
hey, you're the TikTok
guy, in the last month.
I know that that means that it's working.
And once you get the attention,
you're building brand.
And if TikTok disappears tomorrow
and I go take those 16-year-old fans
and we are interacting
on YouTube, podcasts,
and my text platform, 212-931-5731,
for everybody who's listening.
Once you have the attention,
you get to siphon it.
I'll leave you with this and
this is a long-winded answer.
- [Man] No, no, this is good.
I want everybody to hear it.
- When Seinfeld's the
number one show on TV,
you run commercials on it.
Nobody cries when Seinfeld
then stops airing.
That brand goes and runs
commercials on Empire
or The Masked Singer, whatever.
I don't know why people are so obsessed
with a social media platform
sticking around forever.
I don't care if any of
them stick around forever,
I care about when the attention's on them,
am I the best executor of
content on it to siphon brand
and awareness to keep
moving the train along?
(soul music)
We're in Denver, Colorado.
I've come to speak to an
entire room full of executives
from fast casual, QSR, the
food industry, the emergers
and the establishment.
Great space for me.
A lot of my belief of
communication is affecting
the restaurant industry,
the fast food places,
the sit-down places,
just really affecting.
And so, I have a lot of points of view
on how they're communicating
from a marketing standpoint.
Way too traditional.
There's so much opportunity.
And so, I'm excited about
this talk quite a bit.
(soft music)
I come to every speech the same way,
which is I'm so flattered to be there,
I'm so humbled to be
compensated the way I am,
I'm desperate to bring the most value.
And the way that I know how to do that
is to put the truths that
are actually happening
in the system and are obvious to me
on a plate in front of the audience.
I know that 95% of the
people do nothing about it,
but I am telling you right now
for the 5% here that will
consider it, here's the formula,
here's the prescription.
You have to become,
you, you have to become somebody
that knows how to run ads
and makes pictures, videos, and audio
on these 10 social networks
from LinkedIn, Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube, you.
You have to understand it cold.
You cannot outsource this
because how will you hire people
or hire partners to do it if
you don't know how to judge it?
And so, all that effort into figuring out
the perfect location because of traffic
and all that arbitrage, or
the decorations of within,
or all those things.
They still matter, but
every second that goes by,
they matter less.
And the ability to know how to
run an Instagram swipe up ad
for $3 CPMs within a
four-mile radius of your store
against 44 different pieces of creative
to make all those citizens feel contextual
to then convert into traffic
and higher receipt spend.
That matters more and will continue to.
If you don't have a TikTok
and LinkedIn strategy
for your restaurants right now,
you're making a mistake
'cause they're the two places
that have the most organic reach
where you don't even have to pay for media
to build awareness.
Both seem wildly crazy for this sector
based on what they are.
LinkedIn has historically
been a B2B recruiting place
which has now become really Facebook 2012
and TikTok, everybody thinks
is just for 11 year olds,
just like we used to think Facebook
was only for college kids.
Don't even get me started on the fact
that the 12 to 14-year-old
girl in a family
usually influences the
mom's buying decisions
and she's the one that actually buys
for the whole household.
Please, let's get more thoughtful.
Please, understand where this is going.
If you have not committed to truly acting
like a media company,
producing content at scale,
your competitor will.
(soft music)
You think people got it?
- I think so.
It's very much B2C, I was
curious more on the B2B.
- LinkedIn?
- Yeah.
- Giving them content that
actually brings them value,
not awareness for your business,
which then leads to
awareness of your business.
- Boom.
- Got it?
- Got it.
- B2B companies crush on
LinkedIn if they actually give,
if you do five tips
for a restaurant to win
on Instagram as your post on LinkedIn,
they're gonna be like, who is this guy?
And then be like, oh fuck.
See what I mean?
- What about the quality of the content?
Doesn't matter?
- It's subjective.
Lighting, audio, it's all subjective.
You don't have to fucking make Star Wars.
- Awesome.
Can Alan take a quick picture for me?
- Yo, how is it everyone?
We're with the legend, himself, Gary Vee.
- What's up YouTube, how we doin'?
- Hey brother, how do you
make dreams come true?
- Two ways.
One, actually having them,
and two, not being crippled by having them
and executing on a daily basis.
If you can't pull from both
sides, you're finished.
So, first you have to have it.
There has to be a North Star.
But where people get hurt is
every day they're wondering
why they haven't reached it.
So, I have great ambitions and dreams,
but I don't think about them daily.
I know they exist, but
daily I just execute.
Daily I execute and then
I wake up in 50 years
and see where I'm at.
- Awesome, thank you so much.
- You got it.
Take care.
- [Both] Hi.
- Thank you for shaking
your head in the front.
I saw you and I was like, the
positive reinforcement helps.
- I was just soaking in
everything you were saying.
I listen to you every day on podcast.
I'm shaking right now
and I'm usually a really
confident person (laughs).
- Don't worry, thank you.
- What are some things that you do?
I put my number and then the
question I was gonna ask,
but what are some things
that you do every day
that you think are
habitual, consistent things
that help you make good decisions?
- I keep things in
perspective extremely well.
Both time and how important business is
in comparison to real
life, which is it's not.
All of a sudden, when you
know you have a lot of time
and you don't think
things are that serious,
you're dramatically happier.
Almost everybody's upset
'cause they don't think they have time
and they think everything's super serious.
Every day, I put those
two things in perspective,
which makes everything else pop.
- And almost like done
is better than perfect.
- I hate perfect.
I think perfect is the worst.
Perfect is based in insecurity.
- Right, perfection
paralysis is the worst.
- It's insecurity.
You're scared of other
peoples' feedback on it,
so you are aiming for some
theoretical perfection.
I don't care what they think,
thus there is no perfect.
- That's so liberating.
- It's the liberating key.
- Wow, thank you.
- Yeah.
(soft music)
(engine hums)
Heading to LA now.
As you guys now, I
don't like to get bougee
and go private, but we gotta get to LA
'cause we got a speech there, too.
And then I gotta do
Michael Badgley's podcast,
kicker for the Chargers,
(mumbles) sports guy.
So, I'll be in the office.
Just livin' the dream, D Rock.
Just did a bunch of,
one of the things that people don't do
is they don't max time.
I basically have done
seven or eight phone calls
already today that I genuinely
believe most executives
spend their nine to six in the office
doing one-hour meetings
when they're actually 13-minute
calls, 40-minute calls.
So, obviously sometimes I extreme travel,
yet I still have to run
a thousand-person agency
and I'm an operator.
So, I've had seven client calls,
putting out a fire, doing
a strategy road map.
I've had four or five executive calls.
D Rock and I, I don't think we caught it,
but I got in the car right off the stage,
and he's like, you got a call
and we kinda laughed.
I'm like, it looks good on paper.
I was talkin' about just
like, it's so intense.
Every minute, I just got
off the phone with a client,
now we're just getting on.
I will now answer emails until I land.
It's maximizing time.
People are like, how do you handle it all?
It's by actually being good at it.
You've gotta be good at time management.
You gotta realize, almost
everybody's watching this vlog.
It's spending an hour on dumb shit
that's actually a 12-minute meeting.
Don't make 12-minute
meetings one-hour meetings.
It's nonsense.
- [D Rock] And you're posting content.
- What?
- [D Rock] And you're posting--
- And I'm posting content and I'm thinking
and I'm watching.
I'm fucking out here doing.
How are you?
- Good.
(soft music)
- Yep, okay, I'll let you go.
See ya, bye.
- [D Rock] Literally
until the last second.
- Right, what a great point.
Literally everything that
I was just talking about,
D Rock, to your point
of milk every second.
If I wasn't willing to
do the last two posts,
which both underperformed by
my core metrics on Instagram,
I also might have not been able to get
to the piece of content
that is the new foundation
of my best organic reach.
We are driven by fear in many places.
And definitely in content creation
in the current platform that matters.
Most of you are fearful on
your content on Instagram.
I hope this series of
three posts changes mind.
(soft music)
- [Man] Great to hear you, man.
- Thanks man, I'm getting
excited to get out there.
Take care.
Hey Pearl.
- She's friendly, you
can pet her all you want.
- Yeah, hey Pearl.
Real pleasure.
- Chris.
- I actually brought--
- Oh, I love this.
I love it.
- Okay, I (mumbles) five of these
and I need you to
(mumbles) it for me, man.
- How are you?
- Dude, I am so incredibly
happy to see you.
- Thank you, brother.
Lookin' forward to seeing you out there.
(soft music)
(audience cheers)
Real pleasure, thank you guys for coming.
(cheers)
- Garry, I fuckin' love you, man.
- I love you back.
Please make.
(soft music)
Badge, baby, give me some love.
You been frustrated?
I know you've never missed
any fuckin' football
in your life.
My talent is people, my talent is people.
And so, I understand that
sometimes intuitively
about a human, like I did with Badge.
Other times, it's about trends.
I'll give you a good one.
I knew that online dating,
in the early 2000s,
would eventually not have stigma.
Oh, I got a good one.
Let me go wild on you.
On the way driving here,
talking to Tyler and D Rock,
I'm like, yo, I might get
the LeBron hair implants.
I'm losin' my hair, I'm 43.
I'm like, fuck it, I
might get hair implants.
And they're like, what the
fuck are you talking about?
I'm like, bro, I'm telling you,
this is like online dating.
Right now there's a stigma,
but I know all you 30-year-old fuckers
in 25 years are gonna do it.
It's gonna be normal.
- No question.
- What's that?
- [Man] You just killed Brady.
- Why'd I kill Brady?
- [Man] You said no hair plugs
allowed on the handsome list.
- Well, yeah, okay.
Sorry, AJ, this is how I'm making up
for all of the Patriots
fans that are mad at me.
The bottom line is,
it's about understanding
what humans are gonna do
when they say they're not gonna do it.
People used to shit on online dating,
now people spend 24 hours a
day slipping with the DMs.
Right?
People said they would never have,
again, you guys are youngsters,
but the people listening
a little bit older,
nobody believed in the.
You can't believe how many
people did not believe
in the iPhone 'cause they Blackberry
you could feel the buttons.
That's what everybody said.
People said they would
never go on Facebook
'cause it was college shit and
now every 40 to 90 year old
lives on Facebook and all
the young people left.
Right now people are
saying they're not gonna be
on TikTok because their
11-year-old niece or sister
are on it and they can't
see themselves on it.
I'm really good at saying,
they're gonna say no now,
but eventually they're gonna fold.
I remember a lot of
people disagreed with me
that Facebook would get older.
And the single reason I
knew it was gonna work
was when Facebook was growing,
I started seeing people
that joined Facebook at 22
when they were seniors in college.
Now Facebook was in year
five and they were 27
and they had a child and I
noticed they were putting
all their photos just on Facebook
and I used to call it
the grandmother rule.
I was like, if they're gonna
put their photos on Facebook,
every one of these fuckin'
mothers is gonna sign up
'cause they wanna see little picture
of little fuckin' Michael. (laughs)
And so, I knew that was going to work
and so that's what I look for.
All it takes is one thing.
(soft music)